correctness I'm not saying it's easy an
average of like five point six times per
day I have to stop myself from
responding to all of my hate mail with a
flurry of vile profanities this whole
you know sort of finding a compassion
and common ground with your enemies
thing is kind of like a political
spiritual practice for me and I ain't
the Dalai Lama I'm not perfect but what
I am is optimistic because I don't just
get hate mail I get a lot of really nice
letters lots of them
one of my all-time favorites begins I'm
not a big fan of your political leanings
or your sometimes tortured logic but I'm
a big fan of you as a person now this
guy doesn't agree with me yet
but he's listening not because of what I
said but because of how I said it and
somehow even though we've never met
we've managed to form a connection
that's emotional correctness and that's
how we start the conversations that
really lead to change thank you